if we have
intelligent life here on earth if we
take dolphins pigs
humans from the perspective of like
planetary science
how unique is earth okay so earth is not
a com
common outcome of the planet formation
process
um it's probably a
something on the order of maybe a one
percent effect
and by earth i mean it's not just an
earth
mass planet okay i mean
the architecture of the solar system
that allows the earth to exist
in in its kind of very temperate
way one thing to understand
uh and this is this is pretty crucial uh
right is that the
earth itself formed well after
the gas disk that formed
the giant planets um who
had already dissipated you see stars
start out
with you know the star and then a disc
of gas and dust that encircles it
okay from this disk of gas and dust
big planets can emerge and we have
over the last uh you know two three
decades discovered
thousands of extra solar planets as an
orbit of other stars
what we see is that many of them
are you know have these expansive
hydrogen helium
atmospheres the fact that the earth
doesn't is deeply connected to the fact
that
earth took about 100 million years to
form so we missed that
you know train so to speak to get that
hydrogen helium atmosphere
that's why actually we can see the sky
right that's why the
sky is uh well at least in most places
that's why the the atmosphere is not
completely opaque um
with that you know kind of thinking in
mind i
i would argue that we're getting the
kind of emergent pictures that the earth
is is not
you know everywhere right we there's
sort of the sci-fi
view of things where we go to some other
star and we just land on random planets
and they're all
earth-like that's totally not true but
the even a low probability event even if
you imagine that
earth is a one in a million or one in a
you know one in 10 million occurrence
there are 10 to the 12 stars in the
galaxy
right so you just you always win by
by large numbers that's right by supply
you